bienvenue pour une nouvelle édition du
journal du lundi au vendredi 18h 19h
22h30 et minuit nous faisons le tour de
l'actualité nous sommes le 21 novembre
et aujourd'hui nous parlerons de ces
avocats mobiliser manifestation à
Versailles afin de contester une
nouvelle fois le projet de réforme de la
prof souhaité par le gouvernement
inviter les membres du Conseil de
développement de C50 an en Yveline cet
organe consultatif se prononce à son
tour sur l'élargissement de
l'agglomération les élus interpellés
demain samedi lors d'une rencontre
annuelle et comme chaque vendredi
l'essentiel de la semaine du maintien en
prison de Nabila à l'arrivée de Tangui
de la Motte en Guadeloupe en passant par
le plan hiver du conseil
général et on commence par de la
politique l'UMP qui a choisi ses
candidats pour les prochaines
départementales de mars et il n'y aura
plus que 21 cantons contre 39 et c'est
pour un binôme hommes femmes que les
électeurs devront se prononcer on notera
sur saint-cè l'école la présence de
Philippe benasaya Le Maire de boisarcy
ou encore àelle en cours celle de
Jean-Michel Fourgous reste encore
quelques points à éclaircir malgré tout
comme un Rambouillet où les discussion
se poursuivent avec l'élu sortante
Christine Boutin un accord a en revanche
été déjà conclu avec le centre avec
l'UDI afin de faire barrage au Front
national Catherine zulato était ce matin
à la séance mensuelle du conseil général
voici quelques réactions ont recueilli
vous dire sans langue de bois que des
acccords c'est facile à trouver moi je
vous dis non il est clair que notre
volonté et de faire un barrage parce que
dans ce pays ce qui est grammatique
aujourd'hui c'est que toutes les
formations de gauche ont l'air d'être
très diminué électoralement parlant ça
veut dire que si la droite ne s'unit pas
avec le centre et si nous faisons pas
front dès le premier tour qu'est-ce qui
se passe vous ouvrez la porte au Front
national qui n'attend que ça il n'en est
pas question donc on s'organise et on
s'est mobilisé pour faire en sorte que
dès le premier tour dans nos 21
territoires il y ait des candidats à la
fois soutenus j'insiste à la fois
soutenus par l'UMP et
l'UDI autre élection et autre annonce
celle de la candidature du président du
Parti Chrétien Démocrate à la primaire
organisé à droite et au centre pour la
présidentielle de 2017 Jean-Frédéric
Poisson est député de Rambouillet
devrait offici iser son intention dans
les prochains jours il serait alors
opposé à Alain jupet ou encore Xavier
Bertrand et François fillant ce matin il
y avait donc on le disait une séance au
Conseil Général parmi les décisions voté
une hausse de 0,7 % en 2015 de la taxe
puble de publicité foncière comprise
dans les frais de notaire le taux des
droits de mutation passe de 3,80 à 4,50
% la conséquence des mesures d'austérité
du gouvernement selon les élus même si
cette augmentation qui pourrait
rapporter 39 millions d'euros
supplémentaires ne seront pas suffisants
précise-t-il les
augmentations les avocats pardon
toujours en colère après la grève en
milieu de semaine la manifestation
devant la cour d'appel de Versailles ce
vendredi les représentants des 11
barreaux d'Île-de-France la réforme de
la profession est envisagée par l'État
et elle ne passe décidément pas Mélanie
poket et William H chers confrères ce
moment est un moment historique pour
notre profession puisqueà Versailles est
rassemblé aujourd'hui la quasi-ttalité
des barreaux d'île-de-fance nanter
Versailles chartre esson valdemarne ou
encore Pontoise la plupart des avocats
des barreaux d'Île-de-France a fait le
déplacement ce matin en ligne de mire la
réforme Macron et la création d'un
statut d'avocat d'entreprise et
l'introduction de capitaux ce que les
avocats voient comme une perte
d'indépendance de leur profession on a
le sentiment de pas être entendu
effectivement quand on a un ministre de
l'économie qui légifère pour la justice
c'est vrai que c'est quand
même c'est voilà c'est quelque chose qui
est pas acceptable pour nous il pas dans
l'habitude des avocats de faire grève un
avocat ça travaille 70 heur par semaine
c'est pas son style de vie que de faire
grève on n'est pas là pour battre le
pavé on est là pour plider on est là
pour défendre on a si on l'a fait c'est
vraiment parce qu'on avait le sentiment
que le justiciable était au cœur au cœur
réel du problème alors pour se faire
entendre une semaine d'action a été
faite cette manifestation intervient
après une grève et plusieurs suspensions
d'audience puis comme les avocats
demandaient les renvois qu' avit pas
d'avocat des magistrats dignes de ce nom
n'ont pas voulu prendre les dossiers
donc ça veut dire que pendant 48 he
cette semaine il y a pas eu de justice
dans la quasi-ttalité de la France nous
avons constaté que nous avionons un
accueil favorable de très haut
magistrats et ce qui est un véritable
malheur dans ce pays c'est que ces haut
magistrats ne sont même pas consultés
sur cette réforme les avocats ne
comptent pas s'arrêter là la
mobilisation devrait continuer la
semaine prochaine s'il n'obtiennent pas
satisfaction demain samedi 11e rencontre
élu codeski nouvelle donne territoriale
nouveau défi pour sa-quenttin en Yveline
c'est le thème et pour en parler Yve
lond Dechamp président du codeski
bonjour et Henri Pessard aussi bonjour à
vous vous êtes memre du codeskii
également on va déjà repréciser ce
qu'est cet organe consultatif c'est un
conseil en développement je vous laisse
redonner un petit peu les les grandes
lignes du CODES ski oui c'est le conseil
de développement au sens du
développement de l'agglomération de
saqutin en ivoline donc c'est un une
institution qui est nommée par les élus
constitué de membres bénévoles qui
appartiennent au milieu sociau
économique
associatif du du territoire euh et et
dont la mission est de poursuivre une
réflexion sur le devenir de
l'agglomération du point de vue un petit
peu des citoyens des habitants et de
donc des milieux cités pour faire des
propositions aux élus et donner leur
leur ré véritablement c'est que les
habitants s'emparent des problématiques
du territoire voilà nous nous emparons
de ces problématiques avec le regard des
des habitants et des et de la société
civile et forcément parmi les différents
projets important celui de
l'élargissement de l'intercommunalité ce
sera même une obligation il faudra que
toutes les agglomérations don 50 ans en
Yveline compte plus d'habitants à
l'avenir là aussi on va repréciser un
peu le le cadre légal ce qui attend les
agglomérations oui alors donc ceci vient
de la de la loi sur les métropoles là du
début d'année 2014 qui prévoit d'une
part la constitution de la métropole du
Grand Paris hein sur sur Paris et les
trois départements de Petite Couronne et
puis pour la grande couronne les
intercommunalités ont l'obligation
d'avoir un minimum d'habitants de 200000
habitants comme 51 en iveline est à
150000 à peu près euh donc la question
de l'élargissement de 51 en iveline est
posée par la loi c'est une obligation
donc à partir de là ben la
question c'est d'une part il y a une
commission régional constitué d'élus qui
se qui se prononce ce sont c'est le
préfet qui fait des préfet de région qui
fait des propositions cette commission
régionale constitué d'élus donnera son
avis fait éventuellement des
contrepropositions et le préfet
tranchera en dernier ressort courant
2015 on va dire en milieu d'année 2015
pe près et vous à votre échelle
okodeskii comment vous avez débattu de
cette
problématique disons qu' nous avons
essayé de de d'analyser le pour et le
contre entre de cette grande
égissement mais en déjà au niveau en
2011 nous avions donné un avis comme
quoi il fallait que que l'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin s'agrandisse à l'époque
il s'agissait de s'agrandir au minimum
avec morpa coignère et éventuellement
aller un peu plus loin sur plaisir les
clés donc aujourd'hui
i nous avons essayé d'avancer un peu sur
le plutôt que de regarder le le le le la
demande en tant qu' agrandissement mais
plutôt vers le côté projet quel est le
projet pour une agglomération plus
importante donc
200000 on reprendrait au moins en partie
en améliorant le projet des actuel pour
Saint-Quentin s'il faut aller au-delà
donc quels sont les hypothèses
les avancé par les élus pour amener un
projet euh pour les habitants et les
conclusions seront rendu demain lors des
11e rencontres élu codeskii rencontre
donc entre vos membres et également
entre les élus vous allez les
interpeller sur vos propositions votre
proposition vous n'allez pas nous la
donner aujourd'hui j'imagine mais je
quand même vous poser la question quelle
serait l'agglomération idéale alors au
sein du codeski sur quel consensus
demander la réponse moi tout ce que je
peux dire c'est que euh bah nous
raisonnons euh projet de territoire
comme vient de le dire vient de le dire
henryessar aussi nous avons
euh des territoires à l'échelle de
Saint-Quentin élargie c'est un bassin de
vie donc quel quel projet pour ce
territoire il y a un grand projet à
l'échelle de de du plateau de saclais
depuis plusieurs années autour de
l'opération d'intérêt national et de
l'opération donc de développement d'un
cluster scientifique et technologique
sur le plateau de saclet donc ça c'est
un autre projet à plus large échelle euh
donc la question que nous avons débattu
c'est comment comment organiser C
territoireoi voilà donc là je vous en
dis pas plus je vous ai fait la bnonce
sur la question de de d'une
agglomération d'une super agglomération
de 800000 habitants c'était le seuil
proposé par le préfet de de région il y
a quelques temps tous les élus se sont
prononcés contre vous allez dans ce
sensl aussi 800000 habitants ça vous
semble surréaliste euh bah disons que
c'est une échelle pour le projet de
Paris saclé on va dire maintenant savoir
si c'est une échelle pour un
établissement enfin pour gérer les les
services de proximité c'est une autre
question effectivement parce qu' un
véritable enjeu derrière tout ça il faut
que tout tout monde arrive à fonctionner
les gens ne s'en rendent pas forcément
compte mais qu'est-ce qui va changer
avec une agglomération plus grande
qu'est-ce qui pourrait changer
alors faire une une intercommunalité de
800000 habitants ça veut dire mettre
autour de la table du conseil
communautaire des représentants des 58
communes donc ça fait un conseil
communautaire qui va faire 100 ou 120
personnes à peu près nous avons des gens
de de Versailles des différentes
communes de Saint-Quentin en Éveline de
de Massie de
paliso donc la question est de savoir si
pour quel pour gérer quel projet
ce ce conseil communautaire quoi voilà
aglom sachant que à cette échelle là les
questions qui se posent c'est
essentiellement des questions de
développement économique de
développement du cluster donc de
l'aspect
scientifique développement donc de la
relation entre les établissements
scientifique de recherche enfin
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
et les les industries et puis une
question de transport pour traverser le
plateau euh des questions de
coordination de l'urbanisme voilà ça
c'est des questions principales qui se
qui se pose à ces échelle selon nous
quoi l'avenir de l'agglomération il faut
s'en inquiéter de ce que pourrait
devenir l'agglomération euh commement se
mobiliser autour de ces questions-là
lorsqu'on est simple habitant de 50 ans
en hline sans sen inquiéter je ne pense
pas se poser la question quel avenir
rire pour 50 ans en l'eline c'est pour
moi principalement le débat de demain
entre le codesski et les élus de façon à
ce que ça ça tourne autour d'un projet
et non pas d'un rassemblement de
d'agglomération de faire en sorte
que d'agglomérer excusez-moi du
terme quelque chose qui n'a
pas qui n'aura pour moi pas de tête
c'est l'un des gros points si 800000
habitants en donnant les moyens de
réaliser un projet pour tout le les
habitants concernés peut-être par contre
aujourd'hui on constate
que il n'y a pas de transport pour aller
de l'est à l'ouest ça nécessiterait
beaucoup d'investissement
aussiinrastructure pour ça fonctionne
voilà aujourd'hui quand on regarde les
investissements on on commence par le ce
qui est un bon début par tout ce qui est
grandes écoles autour de sa clé mais
pour nous s cinquantinois on a aucune
notion de qu'est-ce qui va se passer
pour nous et ça c'est ça doit passer par
une explication entre les élus et nous
oui nous avons je vous disais que nous
parlons nous partons des des territoires
nous avons analysé un peu quels sont les
quelle est la la vie des habitants en
fait simplement en terme de déplacement
la communauté d'agglomération a fait un
plan local de déplacement et pour se
faire il y a eu une analyse très précise
de l'ensemble des déplacements des
cinquantinois on s'aperçoit quand même
que la quasi totalité des déplacements
des canttinois se passe à l'intérieur
des frontières de 51 eneline pour tout
ce qui est la vie quotidienne euh pour
les déplacements domicile travail qui
sont à plus longue échance les
saquentinois travaillent aussi bien à
Paris à la défense que que à
Saint-Quentin euh il y a quand même à
peu près 50 % ou un tout petit peu moins
de 50 % des 5quentinois qui travaillent
à Saint-Quentin voilà donc tout ceci
fait un bassin de vie selon nous voilà
donc à partir de là il faut s'organiser
pour pour gérer tous les services qui
dépendent de ce de ce bassin de vie ce
sera le sens de votre réflexion qui sera
présenté aux élus demain lors des 11e
rencontre donc elu kodeski autour de cet
agrandissement élargissement de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin une
dernière question est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que le codeskii est entendu
on le rappelle c'est des conseils que
vous donnez ce sont des lignes
directrices que vous souhaiteriez mais
après est-ce que vous êtes entendu
est-ce que vous êtes écouté avec le
recul et un peu d'expérience ben nous on
est là pour fournir des des avis pour
nourrir la réflexion des élus à partir
du moment où les élus nous répondent en
disant bah j'ai lu votre avis
effectivement il y a des choses
intéressantes on considère qu'on a qu'on
a at apr ça peut sarrêter là il faut
derrière VO on n pas on n pas non plus
un groupe de pression voilà donc il faut
qu'on reste dans notre dans notre rôle B
ceci étant il se trouve que on
convergeou oup sur beaucoup de sujets
avec les réflexions des élus ça on
apporte éventuellement quelques quelques
inflexions quelques idées
supplémentaires mais globalement on est
largement dans le consensus he il faut
bien l merci à tous les deux d'être venu
donc en plateau aujourd'hui nous
poursuivons ce journal avant de passer à
l'essentiel de la semaine dans la
seconde partie des tours par cette
initiative baptisé clic citoyen c'est un
concept innovant qui n'existe pour le
moment nulle part ailleurs c'est la
première loterie solidaire entièrement
gratuite à avoir été lancé sur Internet
deux ivelinois en sont à l'origine yolen
Tor
clic citoyen la première loterie
solidaire sociale et gratuite c'est
l'idée de ces deux ivelinois leur site
permet en visionnant 30 secondes d'une
publicité de donner de l'argent à une
association et en même temps de tenter
sa chance à la loterie principe numéro 1
choisir le projet humanitaire qu'on
souhaite soutenir et dont on va pouvoir
suivre l'évolution concrète notre site
en fait permet de visionner en fait
l'évolution du projet vous savez où
votre don est passé principe numéro 2
offrir 30 secondes de son temps
gratuitement et visionner une publicité
qu'on choisit selon ses centres
d'intérêt et qui ne s'impose pas
attention desè la fin de la publicité
vous avez 4 secondes pour valider votre
don là c'est surtout pour les annonceurs
de leur promettre que l'utilisateur qui
a sélectionné leur pub la regardé du
début à la fin dès que votre clic est
validé vous faites partie des gagnants
potentiels de la lootterie organisé
chaque mois grâce au montant collecté
lors du visionnage de la publicité vous
avez fait augmenter la cagnotte de cette
loterie et l'autre moitié est reversé au
projet humanitaire actuellement les deux
amis démarchent les annonceurs qui
restent plutôt hésitant face à ce tout
nouveau concept il le répète un concept
où tout le monde est gagnant à long
terme il souhaite même développer cette
loterie au niveau mondial on a déjà
traduit le site en en plusieurs langues
donc il était déjà disponible on l'a pas
encore mis en place parce qu'on voulait
vraiment lancer le projet en France mais
on a déjà quelques contacts en Espagne
et en Angleterre seulle condition pour
s'inscrire être majeur et ne participer
qu'à une seule loterie par personne et
par mois les inscriptions peuvent aussi
se faire via les réseaux sociaux Twitter
ou
Facebook l'essentiel de la semaine à
présent comme chaque vendredi et côté
justice la cour d'appel de Versailles
qui a rejeté jeudi la demande de remise
en liberté de la vedette de téléréalité
Nabila soupçonné d'avoir poignardé son
compagnon Thomas Vergara l'audience
s'est déroulé tôt dans la matinée devant
la chambre d'instruction de la cour
d'appel de Versailles Nabila reste donc
incarcéré dans le quartier pour femmees
de la maison d'arrêt de Versailles la
justice voulant l'empêcher de rentrer en
contact avec la victime et sans aucune
transition il fait bon vivre dans les
ivelines c'est en tout cas ce qu'annoncé
l'INC ce lundi 22 communes pour plus
d'1400000 habitants le département est
le 8e plus peuplé de France et avec ses
80 % d'espace vert il serait donc l'un
des endroits où l'on vit le mieux dans
l'Hexagone les Yvelines premier
département pour le nombre de salariés
en emploi stable plus de la moitié des
jeunes de 20 ans ou plus ont le bac 99,9
% de la population a accès à un médecin
en moins de 10 minutes un bémolle
cependant le logement près de 12 % de la
population vit dans une habitation en
situation de suroccupation mais le plus
simple pour savoir s'il fait vraiment
bon vivre dans les ivelines c'est encore
de vous demander votre avis micro
trottoir
oui fait bon vivre juste de gros gros
problème de circulation c'est tout pas
assez de train du coup il faut prendre
l'autobus les gares les billets sont
très chers c'est entre on va dire 1
ville 1000 campagne donc c'est surtout
ça qui est génial quoi la vie dans
leselin c'est bien on est dans le calme
on est bien entouré on a tout ce qu'il
faut qu et on est prête paril oui c'est
plutôt un département agréable après ça
manque un petit peu de de vie dans le
sens petit café sympa petit
centre-eville en ville nouvelle on a
tous les équipements nécessaire pour
avoir une vie correcte tous les
commerces de proximité les équipements
les écoles la
faculté l'actualité de la semaine c'est
aussi le lancement du Plan hiver du
conseil général des evvelin pas de neige
encore en vue mais les agents sont déjà
mobilisés ils sont en astreinte détails
de ce plan hiver du conseil général avec
Catherine zulato et le diine pour les
images rappelez-vous hiver 2010 des
centaines d'automobilistes bloqués un
enfer que les collectivité n'ont pas
vraiment envie de revivre le Conseil
général a mise en place son plan hiver
depuis ce lundi centre d'exploitation de
saintir l'école un des neuf sites gérés
par le Département les camions équipés
de salleuse sont déjà positionnés en
tout on a 130 agents qui sont mobilisés
et en permanence sur ces 130 agents on
en a une quarantaine qui sont placés
sous astreintes donc il y a des systèmes
de roulement pour les
astreintes qui font que en permanence on
a une quarantaine d'agents disponibles
pour intervenir une veille météo est
assurée des renseignements fournis
toutes les heures et qui permett le
déclenchement des interventions le
Conseil général a en charge 1400 km de
route départementale bien sûr on
n'intervient pas de la même manière sur
toutes les routes on a ce qu'on appelle
un niveau de priorité un niveau de
classement qui est prédéfini on a des
routes de niveau N1 qui correspondent
aux itinéraires principaux dans les
Yvelines donc ça ça représente à peu
près 550 km ensuite on a les routes un
petit peu moins importantes c'est les N2
et les routes vraiment rurales les
routes secondaires départemental c'est
le niveau N3 les axes classés
prioritaires doivent être dégagés le
plus rapidement dans les 4 heures au
maximum le Conseil général intervient
donc sur les routes départementales les
voies communales sont de la
responsabilité des villes et l'État gère
de son côté les Nationales des moyens
aujourd'hui coordonnés pour être le plus
efficace possible mais pour les agents
d'astreinte la crainte principale la
neige qui tombe en fin de journée le
conseil est toujours le même surtout ne
prenez pas votre voiture si se met à
neiger au moment le soir à l'heure de
rentrer chez vous faites en sorte de
pouvoir prendre les transports en commun
ou si possible de rentrer à pied mais
évitez à tout prix de prendre votre
voiture dans vraiment s'il y a un gros
phénomène neigeux à la limite il vaut
mieux rester à son
bureau rester un petit peu plus tard le
département dispose de 25 salleuses et
d'un stock de 3800 tonnes de sel un
budget d'achat conséquent de 600000 €
l'an passé faute de neige seulement 150
tonnes ont été consommé le sel restant
pourra être réutilisé cette année le
dispositif hiver prend fin au 15 mars
mais pour leur pas de flocon en vue les
températures restent douces pour la
saison il était 5h28h française lorsque
Tangui de la mote est arrivé à Pointe à
Pitre ce mercredi le marin versaillais a
bouclé sa deuxème route du Rome en
autant de participation une
transatlantique qui a aussi permis tout
de même de sauver une vingtaine
d'enfants retour sur l'engagement de ce
navig au grand cœur avec
Anthony 16 jours 15h 26 minutes et la
fierté de mettre un pied sur la terre
guadeloupéenne le marin versaillet
Tangui de la mote boucle sa deuxième
route du Rome avec son nouveau bateau
pourtant plus de de semaines auparavant
c'était la douche froide alors qu'il
était dans le wagon de tête Tangui de la
M est pris dans une violente
perturbation le système de sa Fran
d'initiative cœur est brisé retour à la
case départ pour réparer l'avarie après
24 heur de mise en état le marin
versaillais peut repartir mais il doit
oublier le classement général désormais
l'essentiel est ailleurs car encore une
fois au-delà de la compétition la
traversée du skipper d'initiative cœur
était une aventure humaine sa
persévérance après son avarie en début
de course et les 240000 clics sur
Internet vont permettre à 20 enfants de
se faire opérer du cœur grâce à mesena
chirurgie cardiaque autant que lors du
vent des Globes 2012 mais en trois fois
moins de temps dans sa catégorie imoka
il se retrouve à la lutte pour la
dernière place avec le seul concurrent
encore en mer l'Italien Alessandro di
Benedetto comme lors du vent des Globes
2012 finalement Tangui de la mode
franchit la ligne d'arrivée de cette
route du Rome 2014 à 5h28 ce mercredi
matin il sera dernier au classement
général mais grand vainqueur pour ses 20
enfants la suite de ce journal c'est
avec cette manifestation prévue dimanche
23 novembre à Versailles à l'appel de
plusieurs ass associations notamment les
associations familiales de France une
manifestation qui vise la réforme des
allocations envisagées par le
gouvernement sont attendu entre 2000 et
5000 personnes Mélanie poet a interrogé
l'un des organisateurs du
mouvement depuis quelques temps le
gouvernement ne cesse de prendre des
mesures qui pénalisent les familles
réduction du congé parental ou
plafonnement du cocient familial
allocation familiale sous conditions de
ressources avec abandon de du principe
d'universalité et cetera si vous prenez
une famille deux familles à revenu égal
l'une avec des enfants et l'autre sans
enfants et bien la famille avec enfants
est pénalisée par rapport à la famille
sans enfants à revenu égal et ça c'est
pas acceptable c'est la discrimination
contre ce qui ont des enfants c'est la
c'est de la contreproductivité parce que
ceux qui ont des enfants préparent la
retraite des autres merci nous avoir
suivi très bon weekend rendez-vous lundi
pour une nouvelle semaine d'actualité
locale des 18h pour le direct nous
reviendrons notamment sur ce
rassemblement qui se déroule vendredi
soir à laavrière un rassemblement pour
le retour à la tranquillité publique
dans le quartier de la gare et d'Orly
parc la population et la mairie contre
les dégradations violence et trafic il
sera aussi question dans l'édition de
lundi de l'ouverture des Restos du cœur
130 millions de repas servis l'an
dernier à plus d'un million de personnes
et ce triste record qui devrait une
nouvelle fois être
battu